oh my goodness I could not be more
excited right now I am on the red carpet
of Super Nintendo World this is the
grand opening of the theme park here in
Los Angeles at Universal Studios and in
my hand I have one of the power up bands
and what's exciting about this is this
plays a crucial part inside of the park
where you actually get to interact with
things and participate in the games and
of course to match my pink outfit we've
got Princess Peach
[Music]
this is so exciting Mr mimo the last
time I saw you was about 10 years ago
and we played Mario Kart together and
now we are here in real life to witness
it in person yeah
so obviously the initial plan was to
bring the world of Mario to life but to
actually see it realized now and for me
to be surprised and kind of like
overwhelmed with something that I didn't
expect
these games being created for so long
and now actually seeing them in real
life how are you feeling about that yeah
um
no so I'm really looking forward to you
know when I saw this in uh actual in
actual real life I was kind of surprised
at how moved I was when I first saw it
and you know I'm I'm really excited and
looking forward to how other people are
going to react to that and how they're
going to feel when they see this place
Mr Miyamoto now you've created such
Incredible characters throughout the
years and now being able to bring them
to life what do you hope that people
leave this park what do you hope they
leave feeling
characters
that's a good question and you know for
a lot of fans they probably have
memories of video game is whether it's
the characters or the backdrops and all
of that but then for them to come to
this park and see that in real life that
I would just love to have that as an
additional memory to the the log of
memories they may have from playing
games now I have been playing Nintendo
ever since I was a little kid so for me
this is I'm getting very emotional just
thinking about it so for the newer
generation of kids who are just coming
into playing Mario uh Mr Takahashi how
do you want like the next generation of
Gamers to kind of start interacting with
Nintendo who may have never played
before
you know there's going to be younger
people who are going to experience the
Nintendo for the first time at the park
and so I would love to see them
experience some of the fun activities
and games at the park art and then kind
of reach out to Nintendo and see oh
there's also these kinds of activities
these kinds of experiences and have
interaction and expand out to Nintendo
in that way Mr Miyamoto so you've
obviously created so did so many
incredible games what advice do you give
to up-and-coming developers to to
further their creativity
is
you know when we were talking it's not
really advice but when we were talking
with the creative team at Universal we
were really talking about the importance
of really creating something
unprecedented and something that's never
been done before and you know when
you're trying to compete with maybe an
existing game you have to kind of
compete in that same field but with uh
instead of doing that I think there's a
lot of joy and fun in trying to come up
with something from scratch from zero
and I would love for people to be able
to experience that joy as well this is
such a huge year for Nintendo obviously
the theme park and the movie so Mr
Takahashi how do you feel bringing all
of these characters to life
um
and so you know there's a lot of
different characters whether it's
Pokemon other you know there's other
many different games but we really have
a wider array of characters to interact
with so um you know as the manager of
Mario I would love to have people
interact with many many different ideas
and uh in our catalog so last question
which is a two-part question what is
your favorite food at the park and what
is your favorite Super Mario character
so I actually haven't had the chance to
try out all of the dishes here at uh the
theme park but I can guarantee that the
burger is a great choice here and do you
have a favorite Mario character overall
characters
through the movie and also the theme
park I think you'll have everyone will
have a lot of opportunity to get to know
with a lot of characters but I
personally want to recommend getting to
know toad he's very cute toad is my
favorite as well other than Princess
Peach of course
I also haven't been able to try the all
of the dishes at the park but the the
beverage the lemon beverage that's there
I that I had yesterday was great that's
amazing well thank you guys so much I
look forward to checking out the park
today thank you
foreign
[Music]
this is where I started crying when I
watched this online it was like my
childhood Mario 64 literally changed my
life like I'm not even joking it
literally defined like my entire life
and I'm standing in it right now there's
a tear I have an actual tear I'm on well
[Music]
my arm's gonna be so tired
oh wow look at Bowser this is incredible
this is so magical like you come you go
inside and then you you go outside and
losing my mom and now we're holding into
the castle
[Music]
even the soundtrack The Music everything
I'm
I'm so happy right now
there is so much detail everything is so
thoughtful like the story of walking
through this ride it's expansive
if you're a Nintendo fan
this is somewhere you have to come
I feel like a princess Bowser I'm here
[Music]
[Applause]
dude this is so exciting
so we're about to hop on the ride we
can't actually film while we're on it
but I do have some b-roll you can check
out
[Music]
[Applause]
we just got out of the Mario Kart ride
this is what augmented reality is all
about like it was honestly shocking from
start to finish when I put the headset
on and I looked down and there were just
coins floating I mean it was like you
were actually in the game like there's
no other way to explain it like it felt
like real life
[Music]
I am just so happy this honestly I would
say is like top three days of my entire
life I had the best time and I look
forward to everyone else getting to
experience this I'm gonna go home go to
sleep and get warm because it's really
cold out here I know it's La in
California but let me tell you what it
gets chilly here
foreign
[Music]